[Music]
now of course last time we saw you you
were pregnant with little Josh and you
see he's eight weeks old today
how nice has it been to be able to have
that family time have that time when you
can just put work aside and be with them
it's important time there's just been so
much grace involved in all of it because
you know it wasn't planned but I did
want to expand our family and I
definitely wanted to have more children
I'm all about preparation and planning
and timing and you know sometimes you
just you can't do it that way or you get
with something and you have to kind of
make it work and it ended up working so
much more beautifully than I could have
ever imagined so it's such a blessing
it's been incredible I've been told
going from two to three is kind of like
exponential on some level how's it been
I think I think once you have to like
three four or five it doesn't matter
anymore eat little josh is not even two
months old but you look amazing
like you know why I'll tell you exactly
what I did I didn't beat myself up like
I normally do and I didn't you just know
sort of emotionally mentally or
physically go I'm gonna beat my body
into submission I just went whoo I just
relaxed about this and sometimes the
more focus I put on dieting and getting
in shape the harder it is for me to do
it for some reason I don't know if I
become more food obsessed or what
happens but this time around I just said
I'm not gonna I'm gonna give myself
whatever time I need and my body
whatever tell me is I know it knows what
to do and
I know what to do and I just don't want
to kill myself over this
[Music]
you